these are Skittles it looks beautiful
and this is Bruno Xavier most of this
product is basically sugar and fat he's
a food scientist at the Cornell food
Venture Center oh
and Bruno is going to break down how
these ingredients make up one of the top
chewy candies in the U.S with annual
sales of over 185 million dollars
when you break the Skittles you will see
that there is a harder shell and on the
inside is a consistency of a very thick
paste almost Skittles did not share
specifics about its recipe but according
to Bruno these ingredients are key to
that texture looking at the ingredients
list and the notational factors we can
guess what is the concentration of each
one of these ingredients in the finished
product so we're going to combine these
ingredients and we'll see what we get
first hydrogenated Palm kernel oil
hydrogenation is what helps this oil
stay solid at room temperature when we
scoop it up it has the consistency of
butter almost maybe a little bit more
solid than butter will be at this
temperature that's why the hydrogenated
palm oil is so important it will remain
relatively solid for a longer time and
give you that experience of chewing into
the product for a little while so we
need fat
now we need sugar the corn syrup will
contribute to providing some chewiness
to the base otherwise it would be just
too hard modified corn starch can work
as a glue to keep ingredients together
Bruno will demonstrate how that works
with a little bit of water you need to
heat up the solution
we're already forming blobs from here
it's acting like a gel already
so now the mixture of water and
cornstarch has cooled down a bit and you
can see that what it was very watery in
the beginning now it's very viscous only
a little bit of modified corn starch is
needed which can help bind everything
together into a paste
very messy
can you play with it a little bit
see what I get
let's get in there
it's happening there you are Skittles
this is a bowl of dough that we the base
that we just made and this is how the
Skittles look like after we remove the
external coating of sugar in color and
outside them so actually this is a
little bit it's slimier than I thought
so it was too much corn syrup you can
see that it's not hard enough if you
compare Bruno's dough to the inside of a
Skittle the candy is slightly more white
and that's why the titanium dioxide is
added to make that base look even more
white titanium dioxide is a color
additive used in food as well as in
products like sunscreen or foundation so
what we added here was probably like
less than a tenth of a percent and the
effect is very noticeable titanium
dioxide was banned in the EU after
scientists could not roll out
genotoxicity concerns but it is still
approved by the FDA for use in food with
limited quantities
but there are concerns and maybe there
is more space for research to be done
then there's the sugar shell the
interesting thing is that whenever you
bite into it you always gonna feel or
hear that crack of the outside layer
right
Skittles has 10 different color
additives on the label all listed under
less than two percent
we can show how intense these colors are
so what we're gonna do is pour water on
this pan here hopefully we're gonna see
the colors diffusing towards the center
color additives with names like yellow 6
or red 40 are typically derived from
petroleum or coal sources and the FDA
approves batches of these ingredients
before use if you eat a spoonful of red
40 you'd probably not be a good idea
some sources have linked specific color
additives to issues like hyperactivity
or allergic type reactions our concerns
around with fishery ingredients are
related to the fact that we don't know
the effects of an artificial chemical
compound in our bodies until we study it
and the shininess I believe the wax is
also used to make the surface of the
Skittles look shinier Cordoba is a type
of a palm tree very common in Brazil
Carnauba wax can be used to polish cars
and make everything look shiny and when
it's melted it behaves just like candle
wax for example it's big liquid and as
soon as it cools down it becomes solid
again actually I had never heard of
Skittles until I came to the United
States so it was fascinated with the
amount of candy varieties that we have
here but it's a very unique product the
flavors are very thoroughly developed
very intense the colors are very stable
and it's a very successful product this
is my favorite flavor the red ones I
don't even know what they call the red
ones I call them red foreign
[Music]